hello everyone nothing spices up a chess
game like an ice queen sacrifice and I'm
not saying this game features such a
move but I'm also not saying it doesn't
the game was played in 1901 between the
American chess master Albert Wyden Fox
and the person named H E Bauer the
hoodie guy again and in those that is
there was a there was a famous Austrian
chess master named Johan Hermann power
but not H E power this is the only game
HG Bower has in the database so maybe he
was a relative to the famous Austrian
master but that doesn't really matter as
the game is what we're interested in and
it's what's even more amazing is that
this brilliant game comes out of a
Berlin defense and you know not a lot of
games are interesting that come out of
the Berlin defense
so mr. Albert Fox is white and HG Bower
has the black pieces we have E 4 E 5
Knight to f3 knight c6 and Bishop to b5
the real opus and 90 to f6 the Berlin
defense white castles and we have Knight
captures on e4 rook to e1 Knight to d6
and now Knight captures on e5
threatening some nasty discoveries with
knife captures on c6 so black prevents
this Bishop to e7 and here we have a
very nice move by mr. Fox
he plays Bishop back to f1 preserving
the bishop and a move like this can be
seen a lot in in Bobby Fischer's games
he really loved his LightSquared bishop
and always saved him to shine later in
the game mr. Bower castles and we have
d4 Knight to a5 now with a double attack
on this pawn white defends it upon 2 C 3
and we have d5 Queen to b3 rook to e8
and f4 Knight to d6 and white plays rook
to e3 and there you have it as you all
know that all great games begin with a
nice rook lift Knight to a5 preparing
Knight to c4 this would be a pretty good
square for the knight although he could
be kicked pretty
would be 3 so 925 doesn't really doesn't
really give black that much night 2d to
fox develops the night and also now
prevents this night from jumping to c4
we have 92 a5 with an attack on the rook
and well what do you do with the rook
probably rook e1 is is the safe course
here but Albert the sorcerer isn't
interested in safety and he goes for
rook to h3 now with some well with some
ideas of grabbing that pawn on h7 night
to h4 a blocking the rook and also
opening up a discovery from this bishop
to the rook on h3 and white pushes g4
now defending the rook Knight to g6 by
mr. Bower and rook to h5 now adding
protection to this knight on e5 and we
have Knight to c6 and well what you play
here is white probably the best move is
well developing further playing maybe
Knight to f3 Knight d2 f3 and I'm
figuring up a finger figuring figuring
out what to do with the Bishop but
Albert has a different idea here he
plays a stunning move and the move is
Knight d2 c4 and what's the idea well
this is by no means a good move by white
but well if you don't know what white is
doing you do have to capture the knight
that's kind of the rule and especially
it was the rule in 1901 as you know it
wasn't very polite to decline a
sacrifice so it doesn't seem like White
has anything here I mean why not capture
the night I mean the rook is the rook is
threatening this age 7 pawn the Queen
doesn't isn't really this Knight is in
the way there is really no way to kick
the night if you push at 5 you block
your own Queen so why not capture the
phone the pawn and mr. Bober captures it
D captures and c4 and now the real magic
begins as the queen is now attacked you
do have to move it somewhere and what a
better place to move it than capturing
this night on g6 and this is what Albert
Fox plays Queen captures on g6 and again
I must
what is this sorcery what do you do here
well in the game power played a H
captures on g6 but let's just cover what
happens if F captures and g6 if F
captures and g6 well then this is pretty
straightforward you get Bishop to c4
with check and you can't block the check
with anything you can give up your light
square bishop and c8 but this doesn't
really achieve much if you go for for
King to f8 well you get Knight captures
on g6 with check and there is no square
for the black King you do have to
capture the knight HK after sin g6 and
out comes rope to h8 with checkmate but
even if you don't go to F ad if you
decide to go King to h8 then you get the
immediate Knight captures on g6 with
checkmate as the point is now pinned so
after this Queen captors and g6 mr.
bowser decided he will capture the Queen
with the H pawn not capturing the Queen
is really not an option as you're
getting checkmate it on all sides so he
played eight characters than g6 we have
knife capture son g6 and again black is
totally doomed white is threatening rook
to h8 checkmate and there's nothing
really you can do here to stop it
the King can't go anywhere you can't
really block the rook with something
only only move black has is actually to
capture this night so he does he plays F
capture sin g6 and now you get the same
idea I just showed you Bishop captures
and c4 only now the king is forced to go
to see it you could prolong prolong your
doom with moves like Bishop d6 or Queen
captures than before but this is just
silly
so King to f8 and here mr. Fox plays
rook to h8 what a beautiful checkmate
so yeah definitely one of the one of the
greatest Queen sacrifices I've ever seen
by mr. Albert whiting Fox the American
chess master and yeah that's the game I
do hope you enjoyed it I would like to
thank comrade obler Sofia Irina Cote and
also happy birthday to you Sofia Aden Co
LLC and Igor dated for a contribution to
my channel thank you a lot I really
appreciate it
as usual you can check to my previous
video see
thank you for watching and I will see
you soon